okay when i do my hand work like a grip
there's that weak point is in between
the fingers
okay so that's where i go out
i do with my inward spiral
same same number spiral
boom
same memory
but don't do it like this
say man where's my
all right
he's got his grip
and
the same thing i'm going to go out
through the fingers when it's down
i'm going to pull this down
pull this down
this way
rip apart
you see so
i'll through the fingers
this time the fingers out out of the
grip fingers out
i move his fingers out this is same
technique okay
underneath
and over the top
fingers out
but then check his center
boom
check
center down
then this is an arm drag but on the
sleeve
just like
get done
just like get them
[Music]
there's the back take the back
party this way
so just like um
i'm going to go to the market
stay in the back
he gets up
and i stay in the map
once you stay in the back i have to turn
when he wait when he turns
[Music]
can't just go here
not in the back okay he gets up i'm not
in the back
i'll have to turn with him start with
him turn to him turn with me
too late
okay
[Music]
as you try to lift him
it is heavy
heavy
and we try to move him he's heavy
his legs and hands
spin around his center let his legs and
his head spin around his center and then
he's like
[Music]
same thing
don't lift his center up don't push the
center up
don't move it back
turn his legs and head around
he's defending
he's defending it
can't lift him okay
so you keep coming around
and i can't touch here
he defends it around
so this
is here
here
depends
don't pick them up no it's too heavy
turn around the center line
the fence
around
[Music]
like super super wide
yes if you can't get to the side
see his legs here
turn
his legs here
so
come to the left
i know it's not natural
same concept
but this time not picking up
the head and the feet
not necessarily i can't touch but same
concept there is a fulcrum
and i'm going around heading back
okay
okay so temmie was uh very very
confident on this to me was it so uh
i'm just gonna use my body
i'll get a little trip in here he goes
slide fly all the way
very common
same thing
boom
he stands up on me
okay
he's trying to stay mobile maybe hook a
leg
inside or
outside he does an anchor
around
into the same time he was
so
you